President Trump is doubling down on his
opposition up at the NFL protest he
tweeted last night sports fans should
never condone players that do not stand
proud for their national anthem or their
country NFL should change policy major
Garrett is at the White House
major good morning good morning a bit of
perspective tax reform health care the
budget all face severe congressional
tests and very soon North Korea remains
a potential flashpoint and yet this
weekend was all about the president's
heated call to fire NFL players who
protest racial injustice by kneeling
during the national anthem that merely
triggered more protests and rebukes
throughout the league I certainly think
the owners should do something about it
not once but twice Sunday if they have
to respect our flag and they have to
respect our country
president Trump amplified his criticism
of NFL players peacefully protesting
during the national anthem the president
set off the commotion Friday at a
campaign rally for Senator Luther
Strange in Alabama wouldn't you love to
see one of these NFL owners when
somebody disrespects our flag to say get
that son of AB the field right now out
he's fired
he's fired
the majority voters in that election
will be white and the president used a
defense he is mounted for those who want
to protect Confederate statues that's a
total disrespect of our heritage that's
a total disrespect of everything that we
stand for the next morning NFL
Commissioner Roger Goodell called the
president's comments divisive and said
they demonstrate an unfortunate lack of
respect for the NFL
president Trump watched some of Sunday's
games and took the protests as a
personal win I watched a little bit and
I will say that there was tremendous
solidarity for a flag and for our
country throughout the day the president
slammed the NFL and protesting players
on Twitter calling the kneeling not
acceptable and said that the games are
boring but football isn't the only sport
whose players are unhappy with the
president basketball superstar LeBron
James called the president a bum on
Twitter this guy that we've put in
charge has taught us tried to divide us
once again the president insisted none
of this is about race he also worked the
NBA by withdrawing the White House
invitation to the champion Golden State
Warriors citing their lack of enthusiasm
of being celebrated by mr. Trump Charlie
all is not lost the NHL champion
Pittsburgh Penguins have accepted a
White House invitation major thanks in
our next hour James Brown of the NFL
today on CBS joins us with his reaction
to the protest and the next steps for
the league